[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
es waren nicht die ersten
höchstleistungen und auch nicht die
ersten medaillen des deutschen olympia
teams in tokio aber heute gab es zum
ersten mal gold gleich zweimal und das
gehört an den anfang dieser sendung
sie sind und bleiben die königinnen der
dressur im team wettbewerb gab es gold
für isabell werth jessica von bredow
wandel und dorothee schneider
das war fast schon erwartet worden
[Musik]
anders bei slalomkanuten ricarda funk
die den parcours perfekt absolvierte und
für den ersten gold jubel des tages
sorgte die 29 jährige stammt gebürtig
aus rheinland pfalz und sie widmete ihre
medaille allen helfern in ihrer heimat
die derzeit von der flutkatastrophe
betroffen ist meine heimat zu sehen hat
einfach unendlich weh getan
und ja ich möchte einfach ganz viel
liebe kraft und vor allem hoffnung nach
hause schicken kreis ahrweiler ist stark
ricarda funk und ihr stolzer vater dazu
den helfern gehört sagte noch in all dem
schutt und dreck sei dieses gold wie ein
sonnenstrahl mehr zum olympischen tag
gleich am ende dieser sendung oder in
der zdf mediathek deutschland macht
derzeit ferien und genießt ein stück
sommer normalität doch was ist schon
normal in corona zeiten die leider nicht
vorbei sind die urlaubsländer spanien
und niederlande gelten seit heute als
hoch incidents gebiet was bedeutet wer
nicht gelesen oder vollständig geimpft
ist muss bei rückkehr in quarantäne
vor allem familien mit kindern trifft
das darüber hinaus denkt
gesundheitsminister sparen laut über
eine allgemeine testpflicht nach für
alle die aus dem ausland kommen egal mit
welchem verkehrsmittel das virus soll an
der einreise gehindert werden berichtet
stefan schlosser
palma de mallorca fuerteventura oder
barcelona viele spanische ziele stehen
auf der anzeigetafel in frage
foto flughafen beim buchen des urlaubs
sah noch alles gut aus auf einmal hoch
risikogebiet es kann ganz schnell gehen
unsicherheit ist in diesen zeiten ein
ständiger reisebegleiter ist natürlich
nicht so toll weil man hat alles geplant
und dann kommt man nach hause muss man
in quarantäne und bleiben die kinder von
der schule
man bleibt von der arbeit ließ ihn
vorbereitet dass wir zweimal geimpft
sind und sind auch nicht im hotspot
irgendwo sondern ruhig schlimmsten fall
muss man dann halt in die quarantäne
aber das sind meinen kopf wer aus
spanien und den niederlanden nach
deutschland zurückkehrt muss von heute
an zehn tage in quarantäne
sofern man nicht vollständig geimpft
oder gewesen ist nach fünf tagen kann
die quarantäne durch einen negativen
corona test vorzeitig beendet werden
dass sich alle daran halten man kann es
nur hoffen im frankfurter gesundheitsamt
haben sie immer noch genug damit zu tun
die kontakt nachverfolgung durchzuführen
allein hier rechnen sie mit rund 400
personen die aus den hochrisiko gebieten
zurückkehren und in quarantäne müssten
jeden tag unmöglich das zu überwachen
wir haben natürlich unterstützung durch
das ordnungsamt in fällen wo wir
hinweise bekommen auf verstöße gegen die
quarantäne pflicht aber wir können nicht
regelhaft 400 personen pro tag und das
über fünf tage besuchen um die
einhaltung der quarantäne zu überprüfen
heißt risiko für quarantäne brecher
entdeckt zu werden gering strafe wenn es
doch passiert hoch bis zu 25.000 euro
bußgeld grundsätzlich können
reiserückkehrer immer auch das virus im
gepäck haben wurden dass
gesundheitsminister jens spahn will
deshalb die testpflicht ausweiten auf
alle auslands urlauber egal aus welchem
land egal mit welchem verkehrsmittel sie
reisen
geimpfte und genesene ausgenommen
gegen mehr tests hätte auch der deutsche
reiseverband nichts einzuwenden aber die
quarantäne müsste nicht sein
wir haben von anfang an schon von beginn
an der pandemie gefordert test statt
quarantäne des ak ii sagt die
überwiegende mehrheit der infektionen
findet in deutschland statt das sind
rund 90 prozent
die urlauber oder die reisenden jetzt
wieder verantwortlich zu machen als
treiber der pandemie ist einfach nicht
in ordnung
und immer mehr politiker schlagen vor
kostenlose corona tests abzuschaffen wer
sich nicht impfen lassen möchte solle
bezahlen
man kann es drehen und wenden wie man
will für ungeimpfte wird das leben
ungemütlicher eine testpflicht also
könnte bald kommen und auch wenn es eine
impfpflicht nicht geben soll
die diskussion über mehr beschränkungen
für nicht geimpfte läuft schon
denn auch hierzulande steigen die
inzidenz zahlen deutlich aber ist die
inzidenz als gefahren seismograph
überhaupt noch geeignet hat ein
schwellenwert von gelernten 50 noch
aussagekraft wenn doch viele geimpft
sind
gesucht wird die neue 50 und andere
parameter die die korona gefahr
zuverlässig anzeigen christian von
rechenberg
es war mittwoch letzte woche da rechnete
der gesundheitsminister am rande einer
pressekonferenz den journalisten etwas
vor
es ging um den inzidenz wert
wenn wir etwas schauen wir haben 75 über
60 jährigen sind vollständig geimpft
nicht so die massen zu nehmen können so
sagen 250 klingt verblüffend einfach die
schwelle für beschränkungen steigt
irgendwie angelehnt an die zahlen decke
impften inzidenz wert gerettet und
angepasst das passt bloß nicht ich denke
dass solche vorschläge auf der annahme
beruhen dass die geimpften gar nicht
mehr zum pandemie geschehen beitragen
gleichwohl ist eine rest
wahrscheinlichkeit da dass man als
geimpfter das virus weitergeben kann
anpassen also schwierig behalten sollten
wir die inzidenz unbedingt sagen
experten
doch wenn sie die lage etwa auf den
intensivstationen nicht spiegelt kann
sie nicht das alleinige maß sein die
inzidenz braucht partner
ich denke wir sollten mindestens fünf
indikatoren berücksichtigen zum einen
die todesfälle
zum anderen die aufnahmen auf
intensivstationen dann die aufnahmen ins
normale krankenhaus wegen kurven und
auch die laborbefunde und fünftens das
wird leider zu wenig diskutiert auch die
zahl der menschen die wegen cupid
arbeits und wiesent fünf werte
vielleicht zu kompliziert vielleicht
ließen sie sich zusammenfassen
fraglich ob die politik das mit macht
allein auf die intensivbetten zu schauen
wie viele vorschlagen wäre laut experten
aber auch zu wenig
ja wir sehen die korona ordnung für den
herbst wird gesucht am 10 august früher
als geplant wollen sich die
ministerpräsidentinnen mit der kanzlerin
zusammen setzen um die weitere linie
abzustimmen heute besprachen sich vorab
schon die regierungschefs der union und
einer von ihnen ist der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder
stellungnahme
schönen guten abend herr c da sie halten
jetzt schnelle regelungen für nötig so
waren sie heute schon zu vernehmen
sehen das in ihre kollegen aus sachsen
schleswig-holstein aus hessen und
nordrhein westfalen genauso die korona
schutzverordnung geht ja eigentlich bis
10 september halten alle für geboten ja
natürlich weil wir dürfen nicht wieder
überrascht werden müssen jetzt klare
regeln treffen und wir dürfen nicht
hoffen darauf dass oder einlade tut ist
vielleicht dass wir über die
bundestagswahl kommen ein wir brauchen
jetzt klare regeln wir haben zum
beispiel auch darauf gedrängt dass die
einreise verordnung nicht erst im
september sondern bereits zum ersten
august verabschieden wird der bund hat
uns das heute zugesagt mit einem
einheitlich klaren und konsequenten
testmanagement deswegen sollte es jetzt
zum ersten acht kommen ist das eine und
das andere was wir klare regeln brauchen
ab wann welche incidents greift und wie
wir maximale rechte für geimpfte für
zweifach kämpfte darstellen können wenn
wir wollen auch die impfbereitschaft
deutlich erhöhen
aber der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen und kanzlerkandidat
armin laschet drückt nicht so aufs tempo
wie sie hat man den eindruck im
vordergrund steht für ihn ja zunächst
mal intensiver für das impfen zu werben
damit die quote besser wird und je
besser die impfquote umso mehr freiheit
kann man im herbst gewähren ist das
nicht der richtige weg
es gibt dazu man es ist ein
ganzheitliches konzept natürlich müssen
wir die impfquote erhöhen indem wir für
mehr instant werden mit
niederschwelligen angebote machen alle
bundesländer sehr sehr gut aber ist
dauert halt länger und wir haben schon
eine gewissen strömungsabriss in der
bereitschaft sich impfen zu lassen
es gibt seit diejenigen die fordern eine
prämie zu zahlen das wollen wir nicht
sondern wir wollen den kernbestand ist
zu erklären dass mit mehr rechten das
impfen verbunden ist steht übrigens sie
auch grundgesetzlich klar vorschreiben
dass derjenige der
eine einschränkung hat nur die
einschränkung der grundrechte haben darf
wenn er besonders gut dahinter steht das
gibt aber nicht mehr wenn man zweimal
geimpft ist du musst sehr schnell klar
sein welche maximalen rechte für zwei
fachkräfte sind das ist ja nicht der
anreiz sich impfen zu lassen
ja da will ich gleich noch mal
nachfragen gegen eine impfpflicht sind
sie alle bisher also jedenfalls auch
anni laschet und sie aber was ist mit
beschränkungen für nicht geimpfte da
will laschet ausdrücklich keine
sanktionen hat im zdf sommerinterview
auch dem kanzleramt entsprechend
widersprochen
während sie sich eben sagen sie selbst
solche ja vorstellen können keinen
zugang zu sport oder
kulturveranstaltungen das wollen sie
einsetzen quasi als anreiz fürs impfen
da sind sie nicht einig sie beide
naja zunächst wir sehen uns relativ
einig darüber dass wenn allen
impfangebot bekommen haben die testungen
nicht mehr umsonst vom staat gezahlt
werden können weil wir können nicht auf
dauer akzeptieren dass sehr hohe kosten
für die steuerzahler verbunden sind und
dass die geimpften quasi die freiwillige
entscheidung impfen ja oder nein bei
denen die nein sagen
vom staat bezahlt werden das zweite ist
maximale rechte für geimpfte heißt das
beispielsweise bei veranstaltungen die
fußballkultur bei zugängen definitiv
klar ist dass geimpfte nicht mehr
dazugerechnet werden und das dritte ist
dann wir müssen zunächst einmal klären
wie die inzidenz zu werden sind wir
wären nicht mit den gleichen interessen
agieren können wie wir es in der
vergangenheit man braucht es als basis
aber was jetzt entscheiden ist man muss
bewährten vom rp ab wann möglicherweise
welche maßnahmen überhaupt zu treffen
sind wir wollen auch keinen lockdown und
klar ist auch jemand der zweifach
geimpft ist der muss immer egal welcher
inzidenz egal bei welchem sie denn
zugang zu geschäften oder restaurants
und die richtige balance zu finden
es ist die aufgabe der mpk jetzt ja
jetzt haben sie schön drei punkte
genannt kommen wir noch mal kurz zum
ersten denn das ist in der tat die frage
ob das ob man das
ob sie das genauso sehen denn herr
laschet sagt ich halte nichts davon auf
menschen indirekt druck zu machen dass
sie sich impfen lassen sollen sie wollen
genau das indirekt druck machen dass sie
sich impfen lassen
nein ich weiß aber dass somit trug
formulieren kann es geht einfach um eine
klare regelung schauen sie das ist ja
hier eine ernste sache über die wir
reden im grunde genommen kein wunder
bleibt da nicht solche mit potenziell
tödlichen ausgang sondern jetzt ist die
frage wir haben eine ganz einfache
möglichkeit maximale freiheit zu
erreichen wenn wir die sogenannte
impfung bei 85 prozent hätten dann
bräuchten wir gar keine maßnahmen mehr
es geht nur darum jeden klar zu machen
was er sich zu entscheiden hat entweder
eine einfache entscheidung für das
impfen wenn er das nicht will
das darf jeder selber entscheiden dann
ist aber klar dann muss auch ein stück
weit die herausforderung die damit
verbunden sind auch annehmen
das ist allein schon grund der rechtlich
vorgeschrieben und das muss man halt
noch mal klar benennen ich glaube dass
diese ehrlichkeit uns auch sehr hilft
die akzeptanz zu erhöhen
ich halte nichts davon dass wir uns
sozusagen über den september mogeln wie
es dann im oktober die zahlen würde
explodieren wieder nur aufs leidensdruck
handeln müssen also sind sie eher beim
kanzleramtschef braun der eben sagt
nicht geimpfte müssen dann eben auch mit
beschränkungen rechnen das haben wir
jetzt glaube ich raus gearbeitet sie
sagt wenn ich den satz ergänzt es geht
nicht um beschränkungen ist das ist
nämlich der duktus der der tat des
spannendes es geht nicht darum dass
jemand beschränkt was sondern es geht
darum dass jemand der zweifach geimpft
ist es verfassungsrechtlich
grundgesetzlich nicht mehr haltbar wäre
ihm die gleichen beschränkungen zu geben
wie einen nicht kämpfen das ist der
hauptunterschied ministerpräsident danke
nach münchen das gespräch haben wir am
abend aufgezeichnet wie viel maßnahmen
müssen sein wie viel freiheit darf sein
die politik mein herz ist in einem
balance-akt zumal mitten im wahlkampf um
vertrauen bei bürgerinnen und bürgern zu
schaffen wird da gern das instrument der
sommerreise genutzt urlaubsorte
inklusive dort erreicht der wahlkämpfer
die menschen entspannt kann aber kite
und persönlichkeit zeigen und kommt sich
manchmal fast in die quere
robert habeck verhinderter
kanzlerkandidat und christian lindner
traumberuf finanzminister waren heute an
der ostsee unterwegs und patricia
wiedemann
war dabei es ist hochsaison an der
ostsee in timmendorfer strand die
meisten urlauber wollen ihre ruhe haben
die bundestagswahl sie ist noch in
weiter ferne
dass ausgerechnet hier nun wahlkampf
gemacht wird und das von gleich zwei
parteien nicht alle sind begeistert
böse schönen urlaub hat und kein bock
auf politik
was natürlich viel schöner wenn man hier
so schlendert weil die erzählt sowieso
alles und da kommen wir mal was anderes
raus
robert habeck der parteivorsitzende der
grünen ist der erste der am nachmittag
reden wird am hafen in diedorf und
pünktlich fast auf die minute zum rede
beginnt fängt es an zu regnen nicht
leicht sondern heftig habeck will keine
jacke keinen regenschirm kein abwarten
die grünen sie sind standhaft sie
trotzen dem wetter und jeglichem
gegenwind seine botschaft nichts soll
ablenken vom wichtigsten thema der
grünen
klimaschutz muss endlich oberste
priorität haben es geht darum die
gesamtmenge die wir im moment an kohle
und gas konsumieren in deutschland und
in die produktionskette reinzubringen
erneuerbar herzustellen
aber schon das ist eine gigantische
gesellschaftliche anstrengung weil es
bedeutet dass wir die menge von
windkraftanlagen und solaranlagen
ungefähr verdoppeln müssen in den
nächsten zehn jahren
anderthalb stunden später nur drei
kilometer weiter mitten im ort diesmal
mit sonne macht der parteivorsitzende
der fdp wahlkampf die erwartungen
diesmal etwas positiver das kann nicht
stören dass man sich über wichtige
themen unterhält oder sich vielleicht
anders weil sie berieseln lässt aber
dann doch mal zuhört und ein gewisses
interesse dann vielleicht auch weg für
die wahl
lindner redet viel über corona und die
folgende einen schlankeren staat mehr
digitalisierung beim klimaschutz will er
anders als die grünen kein tempolimit
auf autobahnen keine inlandsflüge
verbieten neue technologien das ist die
antwort nicht der moral weltmeister zu
werden sondern das land der ingenieure
und techniker muss der innovations-
weltmeister beim klimaschutz wäre ja
noch deutlicher die unterschiede beim
thema finanzen die grünen wollen den
umbau mit neuen krediten finanzieren
die fdp hält an der schuldenbremse fest
nicht mehr kanzler sondern der der
wichtigste minister werde so lindner
wird aus der finanzminister robert
habeck mit aufweichung der
schuldenbremse und höheren steuern oder
wird das an finanzminister der fdp zum
beispiel christian lindner der die
schuldenbremse achtet und
steuerentlastung mindestens den verzicht
auf steuererhöhungen im programm hat in
deutschland sind schulden immer mit
schuld verbunden und es ist schlecht
schulden zu machen aber das gegenbild
wäre geben wir uns kredit geben wir uns
kredite
zwei parteivorsitzende beide am gleichen
ort beide wollen endlich regieren beide
müssen sich möglicherweise in einer
koalition zusammen auf der bullishen
skala sind die grüne griff die pilger
weit auseinander
immerhin einen schönen wetter wahlkampf
ohne regen gewünscht habe ich seinen
konkurrenten dann aber doch noch am ende
des heutigen tages hatten sie ihn dann
sogar beide
die menschen in leverkusen und umgebung
haben einen tag in angst erlebt nach
einer gewaltigen explosion in einer
müllverbrennungsanlage
noch sind die ursachen nicht geklärt wer
jetzt in den nachrichten von gundula
gause ja in leverkusen sind bei einer
verheerenden explosion in einer
müllverbrennungsanlage zwei mitarbeiter
ums leben gekommen
rettungskräfte suchen weiterhin nach
einigen vermissten
bei dem unglück in einem chemiepark
wurden 31 menschen verletzt mehrere von
ihnen schwer
in der folge der explosion kam ist in
einem tanklager eines sondermüll
entsorgungszentrums seinem brand die
ursache der explosion ist immer noch
unklar
anwohner wurden per nina abgewandt
luftmessungen ergaben zugleich dass
keine gefahr für die bevölkerung
bestanden habe die betreiberfirma hat
eine schnelle reinigung der von ruß
niederschlägen betroffenen straßen
zugesagt
in washington hat der
untersuchungsausschuss zum gewaltsamen
störung auf das kapital durch anhänger
von ex-präsident trump die arbeit
aufgenommen
bei dem angriff im januar waren fünf
menschen ums leben gekommen
der ausschuss des repräsentantenhauses
will unter anderem klären welche rolle
trump dabei gespielt hatte ein vorwurf
er habe die nationalgarde und weitere
einsatzkräfte zurückgreifen
zu beginn der anhörung schilderten
mehrere polizisten wie brutal sie von
den randalierern attackiert worden waren
der angriff sei organisiert gewesen im
vatikan hat einen prozess um korruption
geldwäsche und amtsmissbrauch begonnen
unter den zehn angeklagten ist erstmals
auch ein kardinal im kern geht es um
eine verlustreiche investition von 350
millionen euro in eine londoner luxus
immobilie und damit zusammenhängende
geschäfte dabei sollen auch
spendengelder aus dem petersdom
geflossen sein
der prozess wurde auf den 5 oktober
vertagt bis dahin forderte der richter
weitere beweise ein
in hongkong ist erstmals ein urteil auf
grundlage des umstrittenen sogenannten
sicherheits gesetzes gefällt worden
der aktivist enquete wurde wegen
terrorismus und anstiftung zur
abspaltung verurteilt dem 24 jährigen
droht eine lebenslange haftstrafe
kurz nach inkrafttreten des gesetzes war
er in eine polizeisperre gefahren
an seinem motorrad eine fahne mit dem
slogan der protestbewegung befreit
hongkong
auch leverkusen war und ist von der
flutkatastrophe betroffen die folgen des
hochwassers sind auch dort noch nicht
behoben die wupper trat nach den
heftigen regenfällen über die ufer und
setzte vor knapp zwei wochen unter
anderem den keller eines seniorenheims
unter wasser
die zentrale stromversorgung wurde
geflutet rechner telefonanlage und
waschmaschinen sind seither außer
betrieb es vielen ersatzteile trotz
notstromanlage funktionieren bis heute
weder fernseher noch auf züge der
klimawandel das ist eine lehre aus der
flutkatastrophe wird dafür sorgen dass
solche extremen wetterlagen künftig
häufiger werden dh der schutz vor
sturzfluten und schlammlawinen muss
verbessert werden und die finanzielle
vorsorge im jetzigen fall hat das nicht
gut funktioniert und die hälfte der
flutopfer in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen aber schätzungen
zufolge nicht gegen hochwasser
versichert der ruf nach sogar
verpflichtenden elementar versicherungen
wird lauter aber die sind für viele
nicht das mittel der wahl
und das hat gründe peter kunz mit
beispielen aus niedersachsen hochwasser
in niedersachsen 2017 nicht die ausmaße
wie an der aber schlimm genug
auf dem höhepunkt der flut stand dies
hotel hier ein meter 20 tief im wasser
650.000 euro schaden für familie bruns
die lange kegelbahn bleibt baustelle
alles andere bewältigt nach dem wasser
floss auch geld
diese zugesagten hochwasser helfen die
es damals für 2017 gab die sind jetzt
noch abschließend in der prüfung aber im
endeffekt ist da die sache fast
ausgestanden man kann sich glücklich
schätzen dass man in deutschland legt
mauern mit einsätzen für flut tore
unterirdische rücklauf klappen familie
bruns hat in den eigenschutz investiert
beim starkregen vor kurzem hat er sich
bewährt
und da haben die rückstauventile
behalten eine
elementarschadenversicherung haben bruns
aber bis heute nicht zu teuer für den
familienbetrieb auch wenn das
überschwemmungs risiko vermutlich wächst
starkregen ereignisse können inzwischen
große teile deutschlands treffen gut
präpariert sind wir nicht
in deutschland fehlen zb für das thema
starkregen gefährdungs karten wie es sie
in der schweiz bereits seit 2008 zehn
gibt nichtsdestotrotz in § 5 absatz 2
wasserhaushaltsgesetz steht dass ich
alles erdenkliche tun muss um mein
überschwemmungs risiko zu senken an
meinem haus die flut 2017 traf auch
sascha biebel
danach wollte er eine
elementarschadenversicherung abschließen
da wo es schwierig weil die versicherung
natürlich dann auch nicht mehr bereit
waren solche gebäude wie dann zu
versichern
tatsächlich liegt das neubaugebiet in
altem überschwemmungs land gefährliche
praxis klar die versicherungswirtschaft
und wehrt sich gegen eine
versicherungspflicht in den letzten
jahren sind tausende von gebäuden in
überschwemmungsgebieten gebieten die
amtlich festgesetzt war neu errichtet
worden
ich glaube wenn wir diesen weg weiter
bereiten bewegen wir uns in eine
sackgasse
tatsächlich hat auch der staat eine
verantwortung denn wir in der stadt
zulässt dass in bestimmten regionen
gebaut werden davon das ja zum teil
schon vor jahren oder jahrzehnten
dann kann sich der staat auch nicht aus
der verantwortung ziehen und sagen das
übertrage ich jetzt dem einzelnen und
trotzdem kann auch der staat nicht der
versicherer sein familie bruns hatte
ihren hotel anbau vor acht jahren frisch
in betrieb genommen als sie erfuhr
dass er im neu ausgewiesenen
hochwassergebiet liegt ein sehr
geteiltes risiko zwischen staat
versicherer und eigentümer wäre ihr
wunsch damit am ende keiner am überlauf
dich allein im regen steht für die jetzt
betroffenen in den flutgebieten können
sie weiter spenden für das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe für das
wir im zdf um spenden bitten sind
inzwischen rund 52 einhalb millionen
euro zusammengekommen
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
8 190 und jetzt weitere nachrichten
konnte dann die wirtschafts- und
finanzwelt schaut wieder einmal auf
tesla der us-konzern hat so viele autos
wie noch nie in einem quartal verkauft
umsatz und gewinn auf rekordhöhe
stefanie welt damit hat ihre maske ist
mal wieder all seinen kritikern gezeigt
oder ja tatsächlich haben die tester
zahlen heute weltweit geradezu
elektrisiert der pionier für
elektromobilität seit heute ist er ein
in eine neue liga aufgestiegen kein
nischenanbieter mir sondern ernst zu
nehmende autoproduzent der erstmals in
diesem kerngeschäft hoch profitabel ist
im zweiten quartal verdiente das
kalifornische start-up erstmals über
eine milliarde dollar und verzehnfachte
damit den gewinn binnen eines jahres
ohne elon musk hätte es die
elektromobilität in dieser
geschwindigkeit nicht gegeben
doch auch die deutschen hersteller haben
fahrt aufgenommen experten sehen sogar
gute chancen dass vw tesla bereits im
nächsten jahr einholt auch wenn die
amerikaner derzeit noch mit abstand
führen
gut 200.000 autos lieferte tesla im
zweiten quartal an die kundschaft aus
zum vergleich vw verkaufte im gleichen
zeitraum 100 11.000 stromer daimler
23.000 und bmw 22.000 die achillesferse
alle autobauer bleiben aber derzeit die
lieferengpässe bei mikrochips und
bauteilen
hierzulande stehen bereits vielerorts
die bänder still das drückt auch bei
aktienkursen auf die stimmung sämtliche
autowerte heute im
- und an der wall street auch tesla es
bleiben herausforderungen vielen dank
stefanie gerne in deutschland bringt das
wetter nur in südbayern gewitter
möglicherweise mit starkregen schwer von
unwettern getroffen wurde aber der
norden italiens in der lombardei am
westufer des comer sees waren nach einem
erdrutsch rund 50 menschen
eingeschlossen einsatzkräfte evakuierten
mehrere häuser bei parma zerstörten
riesige hagelkörner die
windschutzscheiben zahlreiche autos in
mailand stürzte infolge eines heftigen
sturms ein kran in ein wohnhaus verletzt
wurde zum glück niemand
noch bis ende des monats wird über das
welterbe entschieden
das zuständige unesco komitee tagt und
hatte schon am wochenende drei deutsche
kurorte und das jugendstil ensemble
mathildenhöhe in darmstadt ausgezeichnet
heute wurden weitere anträge aus
deutschland positiv beschieden erstmals
kommt jüdisches erbe auf deutschem boden
auf die liste der unesco genau genommen
das mittelalterliche jüdische kulturgut
von speyer worms und mainz die so
genannten städte gelten als eine wiege
des europäischen judentums schon ist die
abkürzung aus dem hebräischen
anfangsbuchstaben der drei städte deren
jüdische gemeinden sich im mittelalter
unter diesem namen zusammengeschlossen
hatten
ein erbe das fast 1000 jahre
zurückreicht susanne gelhard berichtet
speyer worms und mainz galten einst als
das jerusalem am rhein
seit dem mittelalter waren sie zentrum
des abendländischen judentums prägten
mit ihren gotteshäusern und traditionen
die kultur in zentraleuropa
in speyer war der judenhof zentrum des
jüdischen lebens
neben der ehemaligen synagoge die
mittelalterliche mikwe das älteste
jüdische frauenbad deutschlands steine
die für jüdisches leben stehen für
vergangenes und für künftiges jetzt
gehören sie zum unesco welterbe
ich hoffe dass dieser unesco welterbe
titel für die show städten das judentum
auch normal noch bekannter nacht in
seiner vielfalt in seiner diversität in
seiner innovationskraft und damit eben
auch ausstrahlt darauf dass man merkt
jugend ist nichts separates exotisches
und es gehört zu deutschland und zu
europa seit jahrhunderten die synagoge
in worms wurde 1034 mitten in der stadt
erbaut juden und nicht juden lebten
damals gleichberechtigt zusammen
lange blieb die synagoge erhalten 1938
wurde sie in der reichspogromnacht
zerstört 1961 wieder eröffnet neben dem
friedhof heiliger sand ist auch sie in
die welterbe liste aufgenommen
da wird der jugend um anerkannt und dass
es hat ganz großer bedeutung für
diejenige hierbleiben leben familien
gründen und die gemeinden pflegen
auf dem alten jüdischen friedhof in
mainz stammen die ältesten grabsteine
aus dem elften jahrhundert
es sind einmalige zeugnisse jüdischen
lebens
hier wurden große gelehrte bestattet bis
heute geachtet und verehrt das ist mir
auch ganz wichtig dass eigentlich dieses
weltkultur aber nur lebendig sein kann
wenn man das als auftrag versteht als
auftrag im grunde genau diese geschichte
denen es sehr lange geschichte ist zu
thematisieren auch in ihrer
wechselvollen geschichte zu
thematisieren bis in die gegenwart
jüdisches leben in die welt bringen dazu
soll der titel unesco welterbe beitragen
so viel von uns bei 37 grad geht es
gleich ums glücksspiel und zeit für das
heute-journal update mit nazan guckte
mir ist hier wieder um 0 15
wir sehen uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
schönen abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ja heute gabs ja von westen
her schon kräftige gewitter aber die
nächsten gewitter kommen und zwar mit
den ausläufern dieses tiefs hier über
den britischen inseln
das gehört zu einem konglomerat von
tiefs die sich da festgesetzt haben und
so geht es unbeständig weiter ja und vor
allem im süden deutschlands löst diese
kaltfront dann heftige gewitter aus die
sind dann wieder im unwetter bereich
schauen wir in die nacht ziehen sich die
schauer und gewitter in den süden zurück
oder auch im norden lassen die schauer
allmählich nach die temperaturen sinken
auf 14 grad an den alpen 12 grad im
hessischen bergland und 18 grad an der
ostsee häufig temperaturen um die 15
grad marke also deutschlandweit meist
eine milde nacht schauen wir auf den
morgigen tag gibt es immer wieder
schauer vor allem richtung nordsee auch
gewitter können durchaus kräftig sein
nach süden hin da wird es vor allem an
den alpen zur sache gehen hier ziehen
kräftige gewitter durch teils mit
starkregen und hagel
ansonsten richtung main auch viele
trockene abschnitte temperaturmäßig
liegen wir bei 27 grad im recht warmen
bereich im osten deutschlands 20 grad an
den alpen jesus dann am kühlsten die
kommenden tage
am donnerstag wird es meist ruhig sein
mit temperaturen bis 28 grad am freitag
gibt es vor allem im süden dann gewitter
ja und samstag wird es generell etwas
unbeständiger und kühler temperaturen
dann nur bis 25 grad
ein schöner abend